winter in northern syria can be bitter
and harsh it has still not fully set in
but already heavy rains have flooded
overcrowded camps
home to nearly one and a half million
people displaced by war
the united nations calls it one of the
biggest displacement crises
in the world we saw last year that many
children froze to death in the winter we
have to try to
get people into camps where their proper
drainage systems
where you know there's proper insulation
for the tents
and of course nobody wants to live in a
camp like this this is all temporary
this is all emergency assistance
what people really want is to be able to
return to their homes
but peace remains elusive so for now the
priority
is survival families have been moving
into new camps
but the un says it received only 54
percent of the money it requires
to provide safer living conditions to
all those
in need 2020 witnessed the largest mass
displacement in the nine-year conflict
nearly a million left their homes
because of a months-long russian-backed
syrian government offensive
in the opposition-controlled province of
italy
we now live in a big prison we used to
have our land our home
here you don't know how you will find
food to eat
a life in exile is what many fear
particularly those
living close to the front lines a truce
reached in march remains fragile
we're afraid the regime will launch an
offensive to capture this area
then we'll have to leave and never be
able to return
jesus city is on the m4 international
highway
which the government wants to be able to
connect the coast
to the commercial capital aleppo in the
offensive earlier this year
the regime recaptured the m5 after
intensely bombing and emptying villages
along the route
we saw what happened to the others they
were forced from their homes now they
live in the rain
with no means to make a living at least
half of idlib's population have been
displaced from
other parts of syria people trapped in a
small pocket of territory
where a humanitarian situation threatens
to get worse
it's a reality that doesn't appear to be
temporary
senator al jazeera